>>> TWITTER POSES A THREAT TO
NATIONAL SECURITY AND DEMOCRACY.
THE CNN EXCLUSIVE THIS MORNING,
COMING FROM A NEW WHISTLE-BLOWER
REPORT.
I'M JOHN BERMAN, BRIANNA IS OFF.
CNN CHIEF WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT KAITLAN COLLINS
WITH ME THIS MORNING WITH BIG
NEWS.
>> MASSIVE NEWS.
IT IS INTERESTING TO SEE HOW
ELON MUSK IS RESPONDING TO ALL
THIS.
>> WE HAVE A NEW RESPONSE.
IT IS ALL ABOUT ALLEGED SECURITY
VULNERABILITIES AND
RECKLESSNESS.
THE DISCLOSURE OBTAINED BY CNN
AND "THE WASHINGTON POST" COMES
FROM TWITTER'S FORMER HEAD OF
SECURITY, PEITER ZATKO'S CLAIMS
WERE SENT LAST MONTH TO CONGRESS
AND SEVERAL FEDERAL AGENCIES.
>> IN THIS 200 PAGE DISCLOSURE,
ZATKO PORTRAYS A CHAOTIC
ENVIRONMENT AT A MISMANAGED
COMPANY THAT ALLOWS TOO MANY
STAFFERS ACCESS TO CENTRAL
CONTROLS AND SENSITIVE
INFORMATION WITHOUT ADEQUATE
OVERSIGHT.
ZATKO ALSO ALLEGES SOME OF THE
COMPANY'S SENIOR MOST EXECUTIVES
TRIED TO COVER UP TWITTER'S
VULNERABILITIES.
CNN'S DONIE O'SULLIVAN IS HERE
WITH THE EXCLUSIVE DETAILS.
WHAT ARE WE SEEING, WHAT ARE THE
MAIN HEADLINES OUT OF THIS
DISCLOSURE?
>> THAT'S RIGHT, KAITLAN, A LOT
TO BREAK DOWN IN THIS.
THIS DISCLOSURE IS IN THE HANDS
OF MULTIPLE U.S. LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES, INCLUDING THE S.E.C.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
AND TODAY ZATKO IS SPEAKING OUT
FOR THE FIRST TIME TO CNN.
HAVE A LOOK.
READY?
>> YES.
>> WHY ARE YOU COMING FORWARD?
>> ALL MY LIFE I'VE BEEN ABOUT
FINDING PLACES WHERE I CAN GO,
AND MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
>> Reporter: THIS IS PEITER
ZATKO.
UNTIL JANUARY THIS YEAR HE WAS
HEAD OF SECURITY AT TWITTER, BUT
NOW A WHISTLE-BLOWER.
HE SAID THE PROBLEMS ARE SO
GRAVE, THEY'RE A RISK TO
NATIONAL SECURITY AND DEMOCRACY.
>> TWITTER IS A CRITICAL
RESOURCE TO THE ENTIRE WORLD.
I THINK IT IS AN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT PLATFORM.
>> Reporter: HE HANDED OVER
INFORMATION ABOUT THE COMPANY TO
VARIOUS U.S. LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES, THE FCC, THE FTC AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
>> MAY I ASK YOUR NAME.
>> MUDGE.
>> Reporter: ZATKO IS BETTER
KNOWN IN THE HACKING WORLD BY
HIS NICKNAME MUDGE.
HE'S BEEN A RENOWNED
CYBERSECURITY EXPERT FOR
DECADES.
>> HIS ROOTS ARE IN HACKING,
FIGURING OUT HOW COMPUTERS AND
SOFTWARE WORK.
>> Reporter: THAT EXPERTISE
MIGHT BE WHY JACK DORSEY THEN
CEO OF TWITTER HIRED ZATKO AFTER
THE COMPANY WAS HIT BY A MASSIVE
ATTACK IN 2020, WHEN HACKERS
TOOK OVER THE ACCOUNTS OF SOME
OF THE WORLD'S MOST FAMOUS
PEOPLE.
>> MUDGE IS ONE OF THE TOP FIBER
FIX EXECUTIVES AT THE COMPANY.
>> Reporter: HE'S REPRESENTED BY
JOHN TYE WHO FOUNDED
WHISTLE-BLOWER AID, THE SAME
GROUP THAT DEFENDED FRANCES
HAUGEN.
>> THEY'RE TAKING THIS
SERIOUSLY.
>> Reporter: TWITTER IS PUSHING
BACK, SAYING ZATKO IS PEDALING A
NARRATIVE ABOUT OUR PRVACY AND
DATA SECURITY PRACTICES THAT IS
RIDDLED WITH INCONSISTENCIES AND
INACCURACIES AND LACKS IMPORTANT
CONTEXT.
WHEN WE SPOKE TO ZATKO AND HIS
LAWYER, THEY SAID THE LAWFUL
WHISTLE-BLOWER DISCLOSURE
PROCESS ONLY ALLOWS THEM TO TALK
ABOUT THE ISSUES IN GENERAL
TERMS.
FOR SPECIFIC ALLEGATIONS THEY
REFERRED US TO ZATKO'S
DISCLOSURE.
>> I WON'T GO INTO DETAILS.
MUDGE STANDS BY THE DISCLOSURE
AND THE ALLEGATIONS IN THERE.
>> Reporter: CNN AND "THE
WASHINGTON POST" OBTAINED A COPY
OF THE DISCLOSURE FROM A SENIOR
DEMOCRATIC OFFICIAL ON CAPITOL
HILL.
IN IT, ZATKO CLAIMS NEARLY HALF
OF TWITTER'S EMPLOYEES HAVE
ACCESS TO SOME OF THE PLATFORM'S
MAIN CRITICAL CONTROLS.
>> THERE IS AN ANALOGY OF AN
AIRPLANE.
SO YOU GET GET ON AN AIRPLANE
AND EVERY PASSENGER AND THE
ATTENDANT CREW ALL HAVE ACCESS
TO THE COCKPIT, TO THE CONTROLS,
THAT'S ENTIRELY UNNECESSARY,
MIGHT BE EASY, BUT IT IS TOO
EASY TO ACCIDENTALLY OR
INTENTIONALLY TURN AN ENGINE
OFF.
>> TWITTER ACCOUNTS BELONGING TO
A WHOLE LOT OF FAMOUS PEOPLE --
>> Reporter: THAT KIND OF ACCESS
CONTRIBUTED TO THE MASSIVE
ATTACK IN THE SUMMER OF 2020,
WHEN HACKERS, TWO OF THEM
TEENAGERS, TRICKED A COUPLE OF
TWITTER EMPLOYEES INTO LETTING
THEM INTO TWITTER'S SYSTEMS.
THAT GAVE THEM ACCESS TO
ACCOUNTS INCLUDING THAT OF THEN
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE JOE
BIDEN.
>> I DON'T HAVE TO TELL YOU THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF BEING ABLE TO
BREACH THE TWITTER ACCOUNTS WITH
MANY MILLIONS OF FOLLOWERS
INCLUDING A LEADING POLITICIAN,
THREE MONTHS FROM A PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
>> Reporter: IN THE DISCLOSURE,
YOU QUOTE FROM A WIRED MAGAZINE
ARTICLE THAT SAYS BUT IF A
TEENAGER HAD ACCESS TO AN
ADMINISTRATION PANEL CAN BRING
THE COMPANY TO ITS KNEES, JUST
IMAGINE WHAT VLADIMIR PUTIN CAN
DO.
>> FOREIGN INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO IDENTIFY
VULNERABILITIES THAT COULD HAVE
SYSTEM EFFECTS ACROSS ENTIRE
PLATFORMS, ACROSS THE WHOLE
INTERNET.
>> Reporter: TWITTER TOLD CNN
THAT SINCE THE 2020 HACK IT HAD
IMPROVED THESE ACCESS SYSTEMS,
AND HAD TRAINED STAFF TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES AGAINST HACKING.
>> IF YOU'RE RUNNING ANY SYSTEM,
THE MORE PEOPLE THAT HAVE ACCESS
TO THE MAIN SWITCHES, THAT'S A
VERY RISKY SITUATION.
>> YES, ABSOLUTELY.
I'M TALKING IN GENERALITIES JUST
LARGE TECH COMPANIES NEED TO
KNOW WHAT THE RISKS ARE AND THEN
THEY ALSO NEED TO HAVE AN
APPETITE TO GO FIX IT.
>> Reporter: ZATKO ALSO CLAIMS
TWITTER HAS BEEN MISLEADING
ABOUT HOW MANY FAKE ACCOUNTS AND
BOTS ARE ON ITS PLATFORM.
THAT'S AN ISSUE THAT ELON MUSK
MADE CENTRAL TO HIS ATTEMPT TO
GET OUT OF A DEAL TO BUY THE
COMPANY.
>> I GUESS RIGHT NOW I'M SORT OF
DEBATING THE NUMBER OF BOTS ON
TWITTER.
THERE WILL BE SUSPICIONS OF THE
TIMING OF THIS.
ARE YOU GUYS CARRYING WATER FOR
ELON MUSK?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
WE HAVE BEEN FOLLOWING THE NEWS
JUST LIKE EVERYONE ELSE, BUT
THAT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH HIS
DECISIONS OR WITH THE CONTENT OF
WHAT WAS SENT IN TO U.S. LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
>> Reporter: MUDGE HASN'T BEEN
TALKING TO MUSK IN THE
BACKGROUND?
>> NOT AT ALL.
>> Reporter: ZATKO SAYS HE WAS
FIRED BY TWITTER IN JANUARY OF
THIS YEAR AFTER HE TRIED TO
RAISE THE ALARM INTERNALLY.
HE POINTS THE FINGER AT
TWITTER'S CEO SAYING HAS WORKED
TO HIDE TWITTER SECURITY
VULNERABILITIES FROM THE BOARD.
>> I SUSPECT TWITTER MIGHT TRY
TO PAINT IT LIKE THIS, THAT
MUDGE GOT FIRED AND HE'S TRYING
TO RETALIATE AGAINST THE
COMPANY.
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
THIS IS NOT ANY KIND OF PERSONAL
ISSUE FOR HIM.
HE WAS EVENTUALLY FIRED IN
JANUARY OF THIS YEAR.
BUT HE HASN'T GIVEN UP ON TRYING
TO DO THAT JOB.
>> Reporter: IN RESPONSE TO THE
ALLEGATIONS, TWITTER TOLD CNN
SECURITY AND PRIVACY HAD LONG
BEEN A PRIORITY AT TWITTER.
AS FOR ZATKO, THEY SAID HE,
QUOTE, WAS FIRED FROM HIS SENIOR
EXECUTIVE ROLE AT TWITTER MORE
THAN SIX MONTHS AGO FOR POOR
PERFORMANCE AND LEADERSHIP.
HE NOW APPEARS TO BE
OPPORTUNISTICALLY SEEKING TO
INFLICT HARM ON TWITTER, ITS
CUSTOMERS AND ITS SHAREHOLDERS.
YOUR WHOLE PERCEPTION OF THE
WORLD IS MADE FROM WHAT YOU ARE
SEEING, READING AND CONSUMING
ONLINE.
AND IF YOU DON'T HAVE AN
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT'S REAL,
WHAT'S NOT, YEAH, I THINK THIS
IS PRETTY SCARY.
>> Reporter: ARE YOU NERVOUS?
>> YEAH.
YEAH.
THIS WASN'T MY FIRST CHOICE.
YEAH, I JUST WANT TO MAKE THE
WORLD A BETTER PLACE, A SAFER
PLACE, THE LEVERS I HAVE TO DO
IT ARE THROUGH SECURITY,
INFORMATION AND PRIVACY.
>> OF COURSE, THERE IS A LOT TO
THIS STORY, A BIG PART OF IT
WILL BECOME THE BOTS, ELON MUSK
AND WE ARE JUST GETTING REACTION
FROM ELON MUSK'S LAWYER, WHO
TOLD US THIS MORNING THEY HAVE
ALREADY ISSUED A SUBPOENA FOR
ZATKO FOR THE WHISTLE-BLOWER.
THEY FOUND HIS EXIT AND THAT OF
OTHER KEY EMPLOYEES CURIOUS IN
LIGHT OF WHAT WE HAVE BEEN
FINDING.
SO EVEN BEFORE THIS DISCLOSURE
CAME TO LIGHT, MUSK'S LAWYERS
HAVE BEEN WONDERING WHY WAS THAT
GUY KICKED OUT OF THE COMPANY.
>> THAT'S NEW NEWS, THAT'S JUST
IN, THAT'S A FRESH RESPONSE FROM
THIS REPORT THAT YOU'RE JUST
PUTTING UP THIS MORNING FOR CNN,
DONIE.
STICK AROUND.
WE HAD A LOT TO TALK ABOUT WITH
THIS.
THERE ARE NATIONAL SECURITY AND
BUSINESS IMPLICATIONS, SO
JOINING US NOW, CNN CHIEF
BUSINESS CORRESPONDENT CHRISTINE
ROMANS AND AUTHOR OF THE ONLY
PLANE IN THE SKY GARRETT GRAF.
YOU'RE WRITTEN EXTENSIVELY ABOUT
NATIONAL SECURITY.
I WANT TO START WITH THE
NATIONAL SECURITY IMPLICATION
HERE.
WHEN A WHISTLE-BLOWER SAYS
TWITTER IS A THREAT TO NATIONAL
SECURITY AND DEMOCRACY, THAT
SOUNDS ALARMING.
WHY EXACTLY, WHAT DO YOU SEE IN
THIS THAT IS OF SUCH CONCERN?
>> I THINK THERE ARE TWO THINGS
THAT STAND OUT TO ME.
ONE IS JUST THE SHEER
CREDIBILITY OF THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
PEITER ZATKO, THAT'S THE NAME
HE'S USING TODAY, ANYONE IN
CYBERSECURITY KNOWS HIM AS
MUDGE.
THIS IS ONE OF THE SORT OF
ORIGINAL HACKERS IN THIS SPACE,
TESTIFYING BEFORE CONGRESS IN
THE 1990s, WAS A MEMBER OF THE
PREEMINENT HACKING COLLECTIVE
LOFT OF THE 1990s, INVENTED, YOU
KNOW, MORE OR LESS INVENTED ONE
OF THE MOST BASIC SECURITY
ATTACKS OF ALL TIME.
YOU KNOW, THIS IS A WARNING FROM
CHUCK YEAGER SAYING I'M WORRIED
ABOUT THE DANGER OF THAT PLANE.
THIS IS -- THIS IS SOMEONE YOU
HAVE TO LISTEN TO.
NOW, WHEN YOU GET INTO WHAT HIS
ACTUAL ALLEGATIONS ARE, WHAT,
AGAIN, REALLY STANDS OUT IS HOW
LONG TWITTER HAS BEEN WORKING ON
SOME OF THESE INTERNAL CONTROLS,
AND THEY STILL FAIL.
AND, OF COURSE, MUDGE WAS
BROUGHT ON AFTER THIS INCREDIBLY
WORRISOME HACK OF SOME OF THE
MOST PROMINENT -- MOST PROMINENT
ACCOUNTS ON TWITTER.
WE'RE ALL REALLY LUCKY THAT THAT
ATTACK WAS A CRYPTOCURRENCY
SCAM.
AND NOT A FOREIGN INTELLIGENCE
SERVICE OR A HACKER TRYING TO
START NUCLEAR WAR.
I MEAN, TWITTER, IN MANY WAYS,
IS WHERE WARS COULD START IN
THIS MOMEN